moscú ha seguido poniendo en duda la
tesis del envenenamiento del opositor
ruso alexéi navalni y de hecho se ha
dirigido a darín para decirle que está
esperando que les remita sus informes
sobre los análisis toxicológicos que en
teoría han detectado ese veneno en el
cuerpo del opositor ruso el portavoz del
kremlin dmitri peskov ya ha repetido que
álex en avale antes de ser trasladado a
alemania para ser tratado se le
realizaron todas las pruebas
toxicológicas pertinentes y en su cuerpo
no se encontró ni rastro de ese veneno
pero desde el entorno del opositor se
dice algo muy distinto y se asegura que
han sido las autoridades rusas las que
le intentaron matar envenenando lo oí
hablado con los medios de comunicación
iván es la nov que es el director de la
agencia anticorrupción que creó
aleccionaban y ha dicho que sólo los
servicios de seguridad rusos tienen ese
veneno aviv y que por eso no ha podido
ser ninguna otra persona quien haya
intentado matar al ex naval ni